hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to talk about the twelve scientific
benefits of wheatgrass but before I do I
want to give you a disclaimer I'm going
to put some links down below of a lot of
research that was done on wheatgrass and
in some cases it was significant
improvement other cases cases it was
minor but they did show some benefit so
I'm not making any claims here about
wheat grass as far as curing any medical
conditions okay you can just do your own
research down below when you click the
links all right number one ulcers has
been several studies that show that
wheatgrass is really good for healing
skin okay not just on the outside but on
the inside like ulcers in your gut and
the small intestine and even from
diabetic ulcers all right
burns from radiation or actual fire
wheatgrass can help heal that because
it's a good skin healer it also improves
the topical steroid withdrawal syndrome
which if you steroid creams for a period
of time what happens and you stop using
them your body is so deficient in that
prednisone of cortisol that it starts
getting inflamed and red and very rough
well this would be a good thing to take
orally and even put on topically to help
improve that number four insulin
resistance because wheatgrass improve
glucose sensitivity and it actually
allows the influenza work a lot better
number five anti arthritic so it helps
arthritis and it helps your joints six
blood building in this condition called
thalassemia major which is basically a
very severe anemia that's a genetic
disorder where the person is very
exhausted and tired this has showed some
positive improvements okay
number seven ulcerative colitis that's
like an irritation in your colon because
the colon is basically an internal skin
a wheatgrass is great for that number
eight reduce toxicity from chemotherapy
there so there's the studies I'm going
to put down there you can check that out
but people that are recovering from
chemo hair
the breast cancer there's great
improvements from the toxicity because
they feel very sick and the key with
chemotherapy is is how fast you can
recover from it you know not get a
secondary infection okay number 9 anemia
because we grass has known benefits for
a blood builder okay so then we have
liver detoxification the purifying
effect of wheatgrass in a juice powder
or whatever has great properties to help
cleanse the liver and it has
phytonutrients so how to dismantle
chemicals in the liver tube number
eleven anti asthmatic it's good for
asthma and also anti-allergy interesting
okay so just to recap wheatgrass is a
powerful human and can be used for many
different things thank you for watching